lamb i'm excited because i love lamb
karma chameleon
this looks interesting looks like
diarrhea sorry little
lamb i'm not sorry almost like a lamb
stroganoff
and look at this like viscousy oh not
too spicy
yeah excellent i'm gonna have more
i don't know what this green sauce is
the riddler sauce
a little skirt the brightest things out
of a swamp
it's like mint ooh yum it's very hot not
that spicy this uh bright green kool-aid
sauce is better than you'd expect i
would eat this
all the time
it looks like just has super glue and
you put the rice on top of it and it's
stuck
some kind of sauce
tender really nice his chicken tastes
like coca-cola it's kind of florally
chicken
they really know how to cook their meat
the bones are a problem i don't know
chickens had this much bone in them
i work hard i deserve boneless chicken
smells so good but it looks so gross a
lot of these things tend to look
terrible lined up pretty good like
little peanuts in it
not too strong but this one also tastes
terrible ooh it's spicy
easy to chew dog ghosts all get in my
belly
i think this is excellent this meat is
on point when you're done can i have
this for my dinner
the moon of bread i don't want to toss
it in the air but i won't cause
i could use a dip i could fill up on
this real fast it has like little trees
baked into it
i wanted it to be sweet it looks sweet
to me
it is a weird color what is this a poop
drink
ooh that was a nice surprise yeah i'm
tasting a little mango too
that's delicious like on orange cream
soda i don't like the consistency it
looks like i'm like creating art
what in the hell it's almost like a
fried dough ball but this looks like
parmesan cheese
this is heavier than it looks
whoa really sweet i still have no idea
what the fish
is just take me back do a family reunion
i don't think i want to finish the whole
thing
look at that just like christmas this is
the american speaking you got too much
[ __ ] inside your dough ball it's amazing
i'm glad that i ate it i love it
i thought pakistani food was really
original but it's definitely something
new and
different reminiscence of other cultures
but completely unique to itself